bonjour et bienvenue dans ce qu'imad
nicolas basile bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes vice-président de 50 ans ni
ville délégué à l'emploi à la formation
professionnelle et à l'apprentissage
petit rappel 50 ans neeve il est le
deuxième pôle économique de l'ouest
parisien avec 145 salariés et dix sept
mille entreprises alors nicolas d'un vus
si on cherche des informations sur
l'emploi à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
comment fait on va écouter la porte
d'entrée pour tous ceux qui recherchent
à recruter ou qui veulent être embauchés
ces skis emploi.fr c'est la plateforme
de saint quentin en yvelines qui
concerne l'emploi eh bien écoutez ce que
je vous propose c'est qu'on se connecte
tout de suite sur le ski emploi.fr
[Musique]
ce qui emploie point fr c'est une
plateforme de l'emploi local qui a été
créée en 2018 et qui est gratuite pour
les entreprises du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines à ce qu'ils
emploient on n'utilise quasiment au
quotidien pour nos recrutements
l'intérêt c'est l'utilisation de la
plate forme est vraiment simple et ça
nous permet de recruter locales sur un
ennemi des douanes linkedin ses actes et
personnes habitent en région parisienne
et puis en fait pour les essais qu'on a
pu faire il faut une heure de route
transports en commun puis après ça
marche pas à quoi on garantit un confort
de vie en travaillant près de chez soi
en fait
elle
nous avons cinq cent cinquante
entreprises qui sont inscrits sur le
portail et plus de 30 mille candidats ça
ne cesse d'augmenter aussi bien en
entreprise en candidat quand offre
puisque aujourd'hui nous sommes à plus
de 1800 offre c'est aussi une plate
forme on peut mettre en avant sa marque
employeur ses positions de pouvoir
présenter l'entreprise on peut mettre
des vidéos des liens vers les réseaux
sociaux
voilà donner de la matière aux candidats
pour faire un choix éclairé quand on
postule par exemple sur pôle emploi ce
pas le cas
et puis sur d'autres jobboards c'est
possible mais c'est payant
[Musique]
qui emploi.fr il va aussi vous aider
pour préparer cet accès à l'emploi en
vous proposant des webinaires
thématique sur le cv sur le pitch ou
alors la prise de parole en entretien
nicolas d'un exquis emploi.fr s'adresse
à tout le monde voit un public en
particulier bien écouter à tout le monde
on a près de 550 entreprises qui sont
inscrites
trente mille personnes qui recherchent
un emploi du territoire de 50 ans divine
et ce qui représente à peu près mille
huit cents offres et c'est un vrai
besoin alors de développer une
plateforme pour l'emploi à l'échelle
locale bien évidemment on avait vraiment
l'ambition de rapprocher l'offre et la
demande à l'échelle de notre territoire
on a près des trois quarts des salariés
de saint quentin en yvelines qui
n'habitent pas le territoire donc il
faut vraiment que les entreprises comme
vous l'avez dit on a les plus belles
boîtes du monde on est deuxièmes pib par
habitant derrière paris mais il faut
vraiment que ces emplois s'adresse aussi
en priorité aux habitants du territoire
et c'est toute l'ambition de ski
emploi.fr on a parlé des entreprises
pour elle c'est aussi une vitrine bien
évidemment on a la chance d'avoir des
entreprises très innovante on est parmi
les huit territoires les plus innovantes
du monde selon le m haïti la grande
université américaine le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines qui est le
coeur économique de paris saclay et donc
pour nos entreprises sur des secteurs
très variés qui sont de haute valeur
ajoutée c'est en effet une vitrine pour
rayonner et pour se faire connaître
auprès des habitants skis emploi.fr est
il le seul outil bien vous en avez
développé d'autres mais écoutez on
développe beaucoup d'outils à saint
quentin en yvelines c'est une terre
d'innovation ayant notamment un que nous
venons de lancer qu'ils appellent la
taskforce rh ou alors vous arrête tout
de suite on va regarder ce que c'est en
images
la task force rh donc de saint quentin
en yvelines a été mis sur pied début
2021 par l'initiative donc de thales et
airbus qui sont venus solliciter les
services du développement économique au
plus fort de la crise alors que nous
étions tous confinés pour on risque donc
et acteurs rh du secteur industriel afin
de trouver des solutions
manière collective à leurs difficultés
en fait c'est une formidable opportunité
pour échanger avec d'autres entreprises
du territoire sur les sujets communs que
sont l'attractivité
l'emploi les politiques jeunes pour par
exemple accéder au bassin de formation
afin de recruter nos aux alternants ou
nos jeunes collaborateurs et des
journées découverte du territoire comme
celle d'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment super
intéressant de bien connaître son
environnement pour bien en parler parce
que quand on recrute c'est important de
mettre en avant les atouts de
l'environnement qui font que la qualité
de vie d'un salarié c'est la qualité de
vie dans son entreprise mais aussi dans
son environnement proche il ya vraiment
un territoire très riche
[Musique]
cette année nous sommes en train de
développer grâce au concours des membres
de la task force une plateforme qui
permet d'échanger les compétences d'une
entreprise à l'autre plus facilement
donc il y a une intelligence
artificielle qui maquille et donc les
compétences des entreprises qui
recrutent avec sally des salariés disent
tout
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec nicolas
dainville au ski cube une autre
nouveauté c'est le label cité de
l'emploi qui vient d'être décerné à 50
ans on y vient est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire quelques mots écoutez c'est
une initiative de l'état auquel saint
quentin en yvelines a répondu pour
mettre de l'huile dans les rouages
aujourd'hui l'emploi il ya beaucoup
d'acteurs qui se positionne c'est
parfois peu lisible c'est parfois peu
efficace il ya beaucoup d'argent qui est
dépensé et donc l'idée c'est de
coordonner nos actions pour être plus
efficace plus impactants plus lisible
pour qu'une aux demandeurs d'emploi s'en
sortent mieux et le l'état accordé 100
mille euros et 9 100 % disent pas si tu
exactement cent mille euros par an sur
une durée de deux ans avec un certain
nombre de réunions prévues sous
l'autorité du préfet et de
l'agglomération qui al'autorité la
compétence sur l'emploi lara st quentin
en yvelines où nous sommes rencontre des
publics très différents est ce que c'est
important de faire du sur mesure en
matière de politique de l'emploi bien
effectivement il faut faire du sur
mesure pour accompagner de manière
efficace nono demandeurs d'emploi et on
a répondu un deuxième appel à projets de
l'état qui s'appelle ensemble à 100% qui
permet justement d'y répondre et bien
découvrons justement ensemble à 100%
[Musique]
ensemble à 100% de ses six partenaires
qui se sont associés qui se sont mis
autour de la table pour pouvoir proposer
à des habitants de saint quentin en
yvelines un parcours qui leur permet en
fait de se remobiliser c'est à dire
s'ils sont par en emploi ou si ils ne
sont plus à l'école qui ne savent pas
quoi faire comme formation s'ils
souhaitent se reconvertir mais ne savent
pas vers quel métier se reconvertir ce
parcours va leur permettre de trouver
peut-être la solution l'emploi ou la
formation qui pourrait leur correspond
[Musique]
c'est un parcours à la carte qui
s'adapte vraiment aux envies et aux
rythmes aussi de chaque bénéficiaire ils
peuvent avoir 24 choix possibles
d'orientation à travers ce parcours ça
permet d'avoir des accompagnements un
peu plus professionnel donc soit cet
accompagnement professionnel il est
plutôt liée aux métiers du numérique
donc à travers un bootcamp de dix jours
pour découvrir si métiers du numérique
ça peut être développeur web web
designers ou encore les métiers liés au
tour de la cybersécurité donc plutôt des
métiers d'avenir autour du numérique ou
encore à travers un simulateur
d'entreprise un métier vous a passionné
vous avez envie d'en savoir plus et bien
là on va approfondir ce métier pendant
deux mois et vous allez pouvoir
travailler sur des projets réels donc à
travers ce simulateur a contrario le
numérique c'est pas du tout quelque
chose qui va vous intéresser et bien là
on a notre partenaire face yvelines qui
lui propose des accompagnements donc à
travers par exemple des parrainages c1
salariés d'entreprises qui va vous
accompagner sur comment vous exprimer à
l'oral pour un entretien d'embauché sur
comment faire votre cv et votre lettre
de motivation ça peut aussi être une
découverte des métiers locaux des
entreprises locales de saint quentin qui
recrutent et vous avez divers
possibilité vraiment en fonction de ce
que vous voulez faire et rien n'est figé
[Musique]
ensemble à 100% s'appuie beaucoup sur le
numérique est ce que vous avez des
conseils supplémentaires à nous donner
il a écouté c'est vrai que quand on
recherche un emploi quand on est jeune
quand on s'oriente il faut regarder les
métiers en tension les métiers qui
recrutent et c'est vrai que le numérique
on fait vraiment partie notamment sur la
question de la cyber sécurité merci
beaucoup nicolas dainville merci à vous
et à très vite pour un prochain numéro
de ski mag
[Musique]